alessia ci puoi spiegare cosa significa
per te essere una persona transgender e
invece cos'è una persona cosiddetta c
stringer è molto semplice in realtà una
persona del gender è una persona che
nasce con il proprio sesso di nascita e
ci si riconosce quindi molto semplice
mentre per quanto riguarda una persona
transgender è una persona che non si
riconosce nel proprio stesso di nascita
e quindi percorre un percorso mentale
psicologico
medico per avere l'aspetto del quale lei
si sente appartenere chiarissimo
una domanda che ci facciamo tutti quanti
ne sono sicura sulle persone trans
singer e
a quale punto oppure come si fa a capire
che si è una persona cresce questa è la
domanda super gettonata me lo chiedono
in tanti in realtà è in realtà non è un
capire è una consapevolezza che tu
raggiungi nel corso del tempo
per me è stato come un puzzle buttato lì
completamente a caso e io piano piano
nel corso della mia vita ho messo i
pezzi in ordine per esempio quando ero
piccola
mi ricordo che alle elementari mi
ritrovavo durante l'intervallo a
socializzare di più con le bambine
socializzare di più con le femminucce
ritrovarmi a giocare sempre spesso e
volentieri con loro non ho mai giocato
che io mi ricordi a calcio con i
maschietti però quando sei piccola
non non ci fai caso perché c'è sempre
quell'innocenza e quindi lo vive in
maniera molto naturale molto tranquilla
chiaramente poi nel corso degli anni
cioè l'adolescenza
l'adolescenza inizia a
arrivare e vedi il tuo corpo inizia a
sperimentare con il tuo corpo a
conoscerlo a capirlo e lì iniziano i
primi drammi perché non ti vedi nel
corpo riflesso allo specchio e quindi
inizia a farti parecchie domande
perché non mi sento a mio agio nel mio
corpo
oppure magari guardi le ragazze dice
cavolo vorrei essere così tutta una
serie di cose che mano a mano nel tempo
arrivano
fino a che poi inizia anche un percorso
mentale perché quando arriva il percorso
mentale vuol dire che lì c'è la
consapevolezza che tu vuoi un
cambiamento e lì poi parte tutto il
percorso medico
benissimo una cosa lungo la vita che è
certo un percorso di consapevolezza
quindi poi chiaramente c'è chi lo
capisce prima c'è chi lo capisce dopo
però ogni caso ogni caso è a sé
ovviamente non siamo tutti uguali certo
secondo me ci interessa anche a tutti
quanti capire quali tipi di difficoltà
affrontano in specifico le persone trans
allora sicuramente come ogni donna le
donne trans vivono le loro difficoltà
ogni
donna per esempio chiaramente una donna
trump non può vivere le stesse
difficoltà che potrebbe vivere una
persona una donna disabile piuttosto che
una donna nera ce ne sono altre
sicuramente la prima difficoltà che si
scontra è un qualcosa di più estetico
allora noi nel gergo diciamo il racing
che cos'è il passing il passing e quando
una donna trans riesce a passare per
donna chic gender come abbiamo detto
prima quando passa perdonaci gender
sicuramente la vita gli è molto più
agiata tra molte virgolette ovviamente
il problema arriva quando la donna trans
non passa perdonaci gender e in quel
caso a livello lavorativo per esempio
molti datori di lavoro non se la sentono
ad assumere una donna trans che non sia
passabile perché chiaramente poi
comporta magari a delle conseguenze
delle spiacevoli conseguenze sul posto
di lavoro quindi non si assumono la
responsabilità di darti un lavoro molte
volte non viene neanche dato una casa
una donna trans fa anche fatica a
trovare una casa in affitto per esempio
adesso andiamo sul lato un pochino più
sentimentale
per quanto riguarda le relazioni
amorose piuttosto che è un pochino più
complicato io per esempio tempo fa sotto
consiglio di di una mia amica mi sono
ritrovato a scaricare un dating up
l'ho scaricato e lì quando mi sono messa
a rapportarmi con i ragazzi perché mi
piacciono i ragazzi poi chiaramente ci
sono molte donne trans a cui piacciono
le donne go insomma
mi stanno iniziato a portare con i
ragazzi e lì mi sono resa conto che la
mia bolla di era la bolla in cui stavo
era il mio scudo e lì mi sono resa conto
che c'era completamente un altro mondo
perché purtroppo non si parla molto di
persone trans in questo momento
soprattutto donne trans le donne trans
purtroppo nell'immaginario che ha la
società sono spesso e volentieri legate
alla prostituzione al sesso ha qualcosa
da tenere nascosto a un feticcio
quindi il trattamento è di conseguenza
spesso e volentieri le domande che mi
venivano fatte erano tutte sul mio corpo
che cosa in mezzo alle gambe che taglia
di seno porti quanto sei alta quanti
interventi chirurgici ti sei sottoposta
lì mi sono
mi sono un po
[Musica]
rattrista perché mi sono resa conto che
il mio corpo era letteralmente carne al
macello di questi uomini curiosi e mi
sentivo vivisezionata in un certo senso
è la cosa che accomunava tutte queste
persone
è che nessuno mi chiedeva quali sono le
tue passioni che cosa fai nella vita ti
piace viaggiare
e lì insomma
è un po un gusto un po scombussolata
tesi perché diciamo che poi perdi anche
un po le speranza se capisco oltre a
questo mi dicevi della terapia ormonale
sì esattamente una cosa della quale non
si parla spesso e volentieri è la
terapia ormonale che a una terapia
medica che tutte le persone trans sia
donne che uomini e intraprendono nel
momento in cui vogliono iniziare questo
tipo di percorso non che sia
obbligatorio per una parte molto
importante del nostro percorso di vita
la terapia ormonale per le donne trans
sono dei farmaci che permettono di
bloccare la produzione di testosterone
nel corpo è un altro farmaco che ti
permette di assumere estrogeni nel corpo
che sono gli ormoni femminili della
donna
allora i cambiamenti ci sono i
cambiamenti ovviamente noi persone trans
prendiamo questi farmaci perché non
vediamo l'ora di vedere questi
cambiamenti
assaporiamo alla prima curva il primo il
primo cappello cresciuto la pelle
perfetta eccetera
però non si parla dell'atto mentale io
per esempio ho mi sono sottoposto a una
terapia ormonale
purtroppo lolo dovuta a stoppare perché
mi è venuta una forte depressione
causata appunto dai farmaci quindi l'ho
dovuta a stoppare e mi dispiace che non
si parla tanto della salute mentale
delle persone trans perché mi sento di
dire che molto spesso è veramente non mi
non dico a repentaglio però va protetta
la salute mentale delle persone trans
perchè siamo pieni di insicurezza siamo
pieni di fragilità e
non dico che debba
essere mi fai pena però sicuramente
secondo me bisognerebbe avere un occhio
di riguardo perché le persone trans
passano tante cose nel percorso della
loro vita come tutti
bisognerebbe portare un pochino di
rispetto per queste persone soprattutto
per quanto riguarda la salute mentale e
fortunatamente tu oggi ci stai educando
questa tematica velo di tornare utile
certo
altra domanda che ti voglio fare oltre a
queste difficoltà che sono specifiche
quindi alle persone trans la società
oltre a queste viene a
complicare la vita a chi per non seguire
le norme di genere allora la società
di base rende un po difficile questo
percorso se pensiamo che pochi mesi fa
il ddl zanda è stato forzato che era una
legge che tutela i diritti delle persone
lgbt chi plus
quindi questo non ha aiutato la
religione sicuramente non ci lancia una
mano a favore ecco insomma diciamo che
nell'immaginario collettivo di una
persona religiosa
di base ci vedono un po come persone ma
lavate sbagliate contro natura
tant'è che in chiese alle persone dello
stesso sesso non possono sposarsi e
quindi è un pochino complicato poi
chiaramente
quando non si conosce qualcosa si
attende no un po a respingerla temi
sempre un pochino respingerla
a volerla allontanare da te e delle
volte anche odiare il diverso
quando poi in realtà non c'è niente da
odiare perché siamo persone come tutti
siamo esseri umani come tutti e ogni
tanto ci si soffermasse a cercare di
conoscere chi si ha di fronte senza
badare nessun tipo di etichetta che non
il corso della vita abbiamo perché è
inevitabile avere delle etichette nella
società nel quale viviamo oggi si
scoprirebbe che c'è un altro essere
umano come te che sei dei sentimenti
ride scherza ovvia perché no
e siamo molto più simili di quello che
si pensa siamo unici l'un l'altro ma
siamo molto vicini a livello umano e
questo sarà ben sarebbe davvero bello
che le persone potessero un pochino
ampliare la mente cercare di capire se
veramente
speriamo di arrivarci bruciamo le di
prima di finire sotto terra ecco
come la vivi bene di farti e oltre a
queste
difficoltà che sono veramente reali
gli stereotipi della società ci sono
comunque delle cose positive ci sono dei
segnali che le cose stanno migliorando
allora quando tu mi hai chiesto questa
domanda tempo fa ho iniziato a
riflettere perché
la realtà che vivo è dura e cruda e io
non mento sono una donna molto
privilegiata ma questo non significa che
io non pensa alle altre persone trans le
altre mie sorelle che vivono una
situazione di disagio persone donne che
ancora ad oggi dalle trans che si
prostituiscono è tutta una serie di cose
e io riconosco il mio privilegio
quando appunto mi ha fatto questa
domanda io ho pensato non lo so forse
non c'è molto di positivo nel vivere
questa realtà in quanto da una trans
però poi ho iniziato a pensarci a
riflettere e ho detto però cavolo ha
sviluppato una bella intelligenza
emotiva
e li ho detto è bello perché anche
l'empatia anche l'empatia ha fatto molto
alla sensibilità a capire il prossimo
capire il prossimo a prescindere come ho
detto prima da tutte le etichette che
questa persona chiaramente io non posso
vivere i disagi di tutti però posso
capirli posso provare a capirli perché
so come ci si sentono quindi la
tristezza la frustrazione l'angoscia è
tutta una serie di cose e questo per me
è un grande valore la
la connessione umana che riesco avere
con le altre persone molto forte e
questo secondo me è molto bello poi una
cosa un pochino più divertente
sicuramente io trovo che la cultura
queer la cultura lgbt è molto
interessante e molto bella abbiamo un
sacco di con e adesso mi viene quello un
pochino più pop mi verrebbe da dire
madonna madonna è stata una grandissima
icona lgbt chi plus ma anche una
grandissima icona femminista lei
ha aiutato nel movimento
dell'emancipazione sessuale della donna
quindi insomma una donna forte che ci
rappresenta una donna importante
per esempio nella moda
abbiamo un sacco di esponenti da poco
scomparso thierry mugler e fieri
nucleare è stato un grandissimo cultori
e un grandissimo artista che negli anni
novanta negli anni 80 ha fatto delle
opere d'arte sulle donne
secondo me se non fossi nata una persona
lgbt una persona transgender magari
questa cosa non l'avrei neanche
conosciute quali sono molto felice di
aver approfondito un po tutto ciò che
c'è di bello anche nella nostra comunità
e c'è tanto bello quindi insomma mi
invito un po tutti a conoscere la
cultura qui la cultura lgbt perché è un
sacco interessante finalmente per finire
con una domanda ottimista positiva
perché sai che lo sono e vorrei che tu
ci dice sì quali sono gli aspetti
sotto i quali è fantastico essere una
donna trans e ci tengo al fantastico
allora
come ti ho detto prima la sensibilità
l'essere umano di capire il prossimo
questo è molto bello
la nuove attività la creatività io
lavoro nel beauty lavoro nella moda
quindi molto bello perché io grazie a
questi mezzi sono
grazie alla moda grazie al make up
sembrano sai no nell'immaginario
collettivo sono cose sembrano cose molto
frivole rocce molto di più dietro perché
io grazie al make up grazie alla moda ho
imparato ad avere sicurezza in me mi
creano una corazza che mi permette di
andare fuori in pubblico a testa alta e
sentirmi me stessa e sono dei mezzi per
me fondamentali nella mia confidenza
quindi assolutamente e vts che dicevi è
importante per te questo tel
per lanciare un messaggio no dire a
tutte quante altre ragazze trans che non
sono sole assolutamente io nei miei
periodi più bui mi ritrovavo spesso e
volentieri a riflettere su me stessa e
quando hai uno stato così forte di
tristezza di angoscia non riesce a
pensare che c'è qualcun altro come te
che vive queste situazioni ea me
sicuramente quello che mi ha aiutata a
pensare di non essere da sola sapere che
ci sono milioni di persone come me che
vivono la mia realtà è che sono con me
anche se non fisicamente ma a livello
umano a livello mentale c'è una
bellissima unione e questo fatto mi ha
fatto molto bene al mio cuore la mia
mente al mio spirito la mia anima e e
questo mi ha dato molto molto conforto
poi assolutamente nei momenti un pochino
così io sono
sono molto favorevole alla la
psicoterapia e mi sono fatta aiutare da
degli esperti
anche gli amici gli amici fanno tanto
gli amici sono sono un tesoro non sai
come si dice chi trova chi trova un
amico trova un tesoro ed è vero io sono
stata molto supportata dai nemici mi
hanno sempre aiutata a tirarli su di
morale a stare con me farmi compagnia
nei momenti complicati e quindi secondo
me questo è un cocktail che potrebbe
aiutare chi sta vivendo un momento di
difficoltà
sì perché alla fine dobbiamo
assolutamente ricordarci che non siamo
solo corpi mani me e io penso che il
corpo e la mente solo un ecosistema
se c'è qualcosa che non va dentro anche
fuori c'è qualcosa che non va e
viceversa quindi bisogna nutrire sia
l'animo lo spirito la mente ma anche
godersi il proprio corpo volergli bene
per cani abbiamo solo uno quindi
cerchiamo di di avere questo ecosistema
il più equilibrato possibile
[Musica]